welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber defense attorneys for
convicted killer Alec Murdock have
officially indicated they are filing an
appeal Friday marks one week since a
jury found Murdoch guilty of murdering
his wife Maggie and Son Paul on their
country estate in South Carolina Murdoch
though continues to profess his
innocence prosecutors claim that Murdoch
killed them to distract from millions of
dollars in financial crimes coming to
light the jury deliberated for less than
three hours before ultimately declaring
him guilty after the verdict and
sentence of two consecutive life terms
that were handed down Murdoch's legal
team vowed to appeal saying that the
evidence and testimony about the money
that Murdoch stole from his law firm and
clients was to prejudicial they believe
that judge Clifton Newman made a mistake
in allowing it in on Thursday Murdoch's
attorneys filed a notice of appeal to
start the appeals process and for now
Murdoch is going to remain incarcerated
so let's break this down I'm joined once
again by Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Brian what is a notice of appeal and
what comes after a notice of appeal
Jesse it's literally that it's a bare
bone motion simply just saying hey I am
representing in this case Alec Murdock
and we're going to appeal it has to
happen 30 days after the Judgment there
are no real arguments needed in it
there's this thing called the mailbox
rule depending on when you put in the
mailbox and when they receive it that 30
days can kind of elapse but you're
supposed to send it to the trial court
the Appellate Court of course opposing
counsel so that you know so that they
know this appeal is coming the next
steps get the transcripts you want to
get each and every word that was said in
that trial court so you can make the
appropriate arguments and the old
arguments are in your briefs which you
filed not the briefs that you're
probably used to but briefs like motions
where you're arguing what the apology
issues is okay so Terry Brian clearly
explained the process let's talk about
the specific grounds for an appeal do
you think Murdoch has any good grounds
or chances for Success well I think the
one you mentioned the fact that the
judge let in all of the Financial crimes
evidence that was a big issue one of the
things judge Newman did is he didn't do
any sort of preemptory decisions he
wanted to wait until something was said
during the trial and that's exactly what
happened the defense opened the door
there when they asked a question about
motive and that's how we got to the
financial crimes now on appeal I do
think there is an argument that it
should not have gotten in particularly
the amount that got in but I like the
way judge Newman did his analysis in
terms of why it should go in it does
have to do it motive it does have to do
with intent so 50 50 we'll see what
happens but it's a good argument well
putting the appeal to the side for a
second there is a lot more to the
Murdoch Saga in fact there is another
death tied to the Murdoch family and
that is of their housekeeper and Nanny
Gloria Satterfield she died in 2018
after a fall on the Murdoch's property
Paul and Maggie were the only people
home when that happened they told 9-1-1
that the dogs knocked her down the front
porch steps Satterfield later died at
the hospital and an autopsy was never
performed so investigators actually plan
to exhume her body during Alec Murdoch's
trial it was confirmed that he agreed to
file a lawsuit against himself to get
insurance money for satterfield's two
sons the only problem is they never saw
a dime Murdoch kept millions of dollars
from a payout all for himself and I
should tell you news Nations spoke with
satterfield's son Tony as well as Tony's
attorney Eric Bland earlier this week
and Tony says he doesn't think that
there was Foul Play
why do we believe that your mother's
body may need to be exhumed if I'm aware
or if I'm saying it correctly see if
there was any Foul Play or anything
do you believe there may have been
uh no I do not
but you just want to be sure
yeah in terms of what it means for the
Satterfield family what is the deepest
basis of suspicion that would warrant
something like exuming a body counselor
well I think it's because
um Alex everything around Alex is uh
danger lies deception we know that he
capitalized on Gloria's death
financially and used it as an
opportunity to enrich himself at the
expense of the boys who were exploited
in this process the police have some
doubts about
Alex's story he told an insurance
adjuster exactly what he thought
happened which was that the dogs pushed
Gloria down the stairs it's going to be
difficult when they exhume her body
Chris to really determine were those
done by human hands are by the Fall that
she flipped twice obviously I've been to
the mizelle stairs and so she had
significant closed head injury and open
head injury with 12 broken ribs all
right we'll wait for details on that the
second day of verdict watch has
officially wrapped into Broward County
Florida courtroom with no decision three
men are on trial for the murder of
Rising rap Hip-Hops to artist
xxxtentacion the victim's real name was
Jose onfroy in 2018 he was robbed and
shot to death while leaving a motorcycle
dealership prosecutors presented a
really lengthy case pointing the finger
at Michael Boatright as the trigger man
Trayvon Newsom as the second gunman and
Diedrich Williams as the ringleader and
getaway driver now there was a star
witness the co-defendant Robert Allen
who pleaded guilty to second-degree
murder and robbery charges with a
possibly reduced sentence up for grabs
he testified against his alleged
accomplices while also detailing his
role in the crime there was only one
defense team that presented a case here
Michael boatwright's attorney Joseph
kimock called a Broward County sergeant
and detective to poke holes in the
investigation the jury is going to
continue their deliberations on Monday
morning so we're going to make sure to
bring you updates when a verdict is
officially reached
and we're also awaiting sentencing for
convicted killer Paul Flores the
California man faces up to life in
prison for the murder of college student
Kristen smart nearly 30 years ago the 19
year old vanished in 1996 while
attending California Polytechnic State
University she was officially declared
dead in 2002 when the case went cold
until 2021 when investigators used
ground penetrating radar on flores's
property to uncover items that were
connected to the case prosecutors said
that Flores was the last person to see
smart live and either raped her or tried
to do so before killing her in his dorm
room they also argued that his father
helped hide Smart's body in multiple
locations in October Flores was
convicted of Smart's murder while his
father was acquitted of being an
accessory to the crime after 26 years
Smart's body has never been found
all right it's time to clear up some
confusion right now in the case against
Alec Baldwin and the prop gun that he
was using during a film shoot that had a
live round in it killing a
cinematographer during a status
conference on Thursday Baldwin's lawyer
told the court that the firearm was
destroyed by the state but just a few
hours later a spokeswoman for the New
Mexico district attorney handling the
case released a statement and she
clarified that the gun itself hadn't
been destroyed however according to the
FBI's Firearms testing report damage was
done to the internal pieces of the gun
during the testing process Baldwin has
pleaded not guilty to involuntary
manslaughter charges he says the Colt 45
prop gun was never supposed to have live
rounds in it the gun went off while
Baldwin's practicing a scene killing
Helena Hutchins and also injuring the
movie's director the film's armor Hannah
Gutierrez read has also charged the
judge set a date of May 3rd for the
preliminary hearing I had a chance to
speak with Randy zelen an Adjunct
professor at Cornell Law about what the
revelations about the gun could mean for
the case
well the defense is entitled to test
that weapon to see whether in fact it
was operable and the government has the
burden of demonstrating that the weapon
was operable at the time that it was
fired so if the gun is in pieces or
there are pieces missing the government
is screwed every single moment every
single thing every single advantage that
the defense can possibly obtain every
disadvantage it can foist upon the
prostate prosecution he's going to make
sure that they Rue the day they
prosecuted his client this case belongs
in a civil court it was a tragic
accident let them wipe him out
financially but criminally he does not
belong to be in the caption of a
criminal case
you can never doubt Randy's opinions he
always lays it on the table so Terry
defense they're saying the gun might
have been destroyed or you know can't be
used I think that signals part of their
defense defense strategy now I think the
professor was absolutely right it does
signal what they're going to try to
prove in court or rather disprove as far
as the prosecution is concerned they are
going to show there's Reasonable Doubt
here that gun was destroyed quote
unquote and you know obviously they're
claiming in New Mexico that it wasn't
destroyed but if in fact there was any
damage at all to the internal workings
of the gun how is it that the
prosecution is going to prove their case
so the defense is definitely going to
use this as a strategy they're claiming
that it's destroyed and you remember
Alec Baldwin was on a show and he was
interviewed and he said he didn't even
pull the trigger so we might hear
something like that as well during the
trial that he didn't pull it in the gun
itself was damaged and there's no way
the prosecution can prove otherwise well
Brian neither the judge nor the
prosecution responded when the defense
mentioned the destroyed gun what's the
court ultimately going to do when they
have to decide this issue well for
really and I'm sorry to be the
contrarian I have to disagree with Terry
and even the professor think of it this
way remember the Alec Murdock case when
the prosecution quote unquote destroyed
the shirt through the blood spatter
testing and their defense wasn't able to
test it yeah that was a good argument
but was it really the landslide argument
that the defense had no the defense is
gonna make the argument like Terry said
the judgment will say hey nothing I can
really do maybe go test a similar gun
and make those arguments but you can't
test the actual gun yes they get maybe a
negative inference yeah they maybe get
an argument on the paper big win for the
defense but in actual practice it's not
really much all right we'll see I I
don't know this is the weapon this is
the key weapon though we'll see which
way this goes I can't tell